-I want to talk about
Sam Nunberg real quick.
He -- an ex-Trump aide who had
sort of, you know,
kind of dominated
cable news for...
-Yeah.
-...a 24-hour period
when he -- melted down
maybe is a little unkind.
But he was off the rails
as far as somebody talking
about his time in front
of the Mueller investigation.
Nunberg was the one who brought
you to Mar-a-Lago.
He was the one who thought it
was a good idea for you
to travel with Trump then.
-Yes.
-And so then you wrote this
unflattering piece,
and Trump was not happy
with Nunberg.
-Yeah, Trump fired him
because of the piece,
then rehired him later
and then fired him again.
The thing about Sam Nunberg
that I realized
when I was kind of
stuck at Mar-a-Lago with him
was that he is part of
this kind of rotating cast
of, like, kind of
weird characters
that Trump has always
liked to have around him
who are all sort of aspiring
mini Trumps, you know?
-Yeah.
-Like, they dress like him.
They kind of take on his affect
and his, like,
his linguistic stylings.
Like, they'll use
the same words as him.
And they all try to mimic
his kind of performance.
And it's funny because, like,
you know, he fires people
and hires people all the time.
But even now in the White House,
he keeps people
like that around.
And he sets up this kind of --
the environment he fosters
is sort of like
"The Hunger Games,"
where he puts all -- he pits
his aides against each other
and kind of feels like
whoever is able to survive
and emerge victorious,
that's the best person
to have around him.
-And so the reports
obviously of chaos --
well, it seems like
what you're saying
is he likes chaos,
but he does not care for
the reports of chaos.
-Right. He likes chaos.
He just doesn't like the media
calling it chaos, right?
-Right.
-I think he actually does
thrive in this kind of --
this chaotic environment.
He fosters it.
He did at the Trump organization
before he was president.
He does now in the White House.
But what he doesn't like is when
the media is constantly saying,
you know, "Another chaotic day
in the White House."
You know? And your nightly
monologues about --
he probably doesn't care
for those either.
But the thing is he does --
it's funny.
I think he likes the stories
about, you know,
his people on the brink
of being fired.
-Yeah.
-Because if you think about it,
he's always had -- ever since
his "Apprentice" days,
he's loved --
he doesn't actually like
the act of firing people.
You know, we've seen reporting
about this.
He doesn't like sitting down
with the staffer and saying,
"I'm sorry,
this isn't working out."
But he likes performing his
authority and his power, right?
-Yeah.
-He likes, you know --
Even on "The Apprentice,"
he would practice
the delivery of his line
and, like,
the swivel of his finger
when he, like, pointed
to the person being fired.
And he still does that.
Like, he likes the performance
of, like,
"Look how powerful I am.
"Everyone's fate is in my hand,
and I get to decide
which subordinates will survive
and which ones won't."
All of that stuff is --
he loves.
He just doesn't like
when we call it chaos.
-So, and has this been --
you know, people ask me
all the time for my job,
has it been
just a fascinating time
to work in Washington, D.C.?
Are you going to look back on it
and say, "Oh, I'm so happy
I worked there"?
Or are you going to look back
and say,
"I wish I had any other job
in the world"?
-[ Laughs ] No, I mean,
I'm glad that I have,
you know, this, like, front-row
seat to this historic thing.
It's just hard because I don't
know how it's going to turn out.
-Yeah.
-And nobody does.
And obviously those of us who
got his presidential aspirations
so wrong are very careful
with predictions.
-Yeah.
-But maybe we'll look back
at this time as, like, a great
moment in American history.
-And maybe we won't.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's for -- well, here's
hoping for your and I's sakes
it's great.
-Yeah, it makes me optimistic.
-Yeah, it turns out great.
And you and I get statues.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Thanks so much for being here.
McKay Coppins, everybody.